wir sind ja nicht und olli wir haben
zusammen einen youtube-kanal namens rief
im märchen hören wir heute von zdf plan
b hier zu einem supermarkt bestellt
wissen noch gar nicht was uns erwartet
zdf plan b was ist das überhaupt
konstruktiver journalismus er sich nicht
nur mit problemen sondern auch mit
lösungen beschäftigt passt ganz gut
zurecht ja das steht ihr mann ich bin
frank lenz von der bundesanstalt für
landwirtschaft und ich habe eine
challenge für euch liberec nation heute
müsst ihr euch in einer koch challandes
gegeneinander beweisen wobei kocht euer
persönliches lieblings spaghetti
bolognese gericht für zwei personen
begleitet und bewertet werdet ihr von
einem experten der bundesanstalt für
landwirtschaft und ernährung und einem
profikoch nach folgenden kriterien co2
fußabdruck der zutaten
geschmack arbeitsaufwand beziehungsweise
zeit koch geschickt und kosten was sie
zu hören wie die zutaten geschmack muss
man jetzt ein bisschen freestylen wir
sind jetzt nicht so die kof experten
würde schon sagen aber wir versuchen uns
dann nicht jetzt mit euch einkaufen und
ihr könnt mich jeder zwei fragen stellen
zum thema co2 wir am besten ein kauf ok
hackfleisch werde ich mir schon mal
definitiv nicht holen
rein aus ethischen gründen und vor allem
aber auch wegen dem co2 fußabdrucks
entweder linsenbold oder soja geht sie
haben ja schon mal da könnt ihr jetzt
mal schauen ob ihr aus welchem land
kommen nicht
mannheim ich dachte jetzt eher so an
italien und hier habe ich entdeckt
umwelt schonen produktion die an die
zukunft denken und entscheiden sich für
diese variante auf jeden fall eines
diesel mit sehr schön verpackt haben wir
mitnehmen schwierigste ist jetzt das
hackfleisch zu ersetzen meine grund
gegangen waren entweder ja das mit hoch
und zu machen oder aber was sich auch
spontan überlegt haben das hat
vielleicht mit blinden zu ersetzen ich
kann mir vorstellen dass du die
konsistenz auch so ähnlich ist und wenn
sie da sind ja auch sehr gesund joker
als hackfleisch ersatz dachte ich jetzt
am zwei zutaten einmal an rote linsen
und an soja soja geschnetzeltes mäßig da
ist meine frage wissen sie was
niedrigeren co2 fußabdruck hat von
diesen beiden lebens verwenden was ist
vielleicht stärker verarbeitet haben
eine idee
tofu soja macht sinn weil linsen sind
ist der daten gehabt ist ja ein
naturprodukt also habe ich ein co2
verbrauch von 1,7 kilo je kilogramm
kufen verdienst habe ich jetzt nicht den
kopf ist aber deutlich darunter
darunter das ist doch schon mal eine
interessante instrumente arbeiten kann
muss ich den sie nur noch finden
helens erleben wir haben jetzt hier
zweimal rote linsen ja beides
bioprodukte einmal steht drauf aus der
türkei einmal steht hier nur der
firmensitz frau erst in deutschland
nicht eu das nicht eu landwirtschaft
das heißt dass vielleicht schon okay
mehr erfahre ich nicht mehr erfahre ich
nicht okay das könnte natürlich noch
weiter wächst sein als türkei also
entscheiden wir uns für die türkei ich
weiß ja der yannick ist jetzt nicht so
der koch der ist ein bisschen
ausgefuchst hat ich muss ich zugeben
weil ich will dass ein bisschen extra
ordinärer gut die würde ich sowieso
ausscheiden lassen allein dinge in
plastik sind in der plastikverpackung
ich mir ich mache immer so wenn ich zwei
lebensmittelriese plastik wohl nicht was
ich entscheide ich mich immer für die
variante ohne plastik und dann wollte
ich noch eine zitrone reinmachen ein
bisschen bisserl ich finde ich
persönlich auch immer sehr lecker ich
war nicht optimal aber spanien ist nach
europa aber für den geschmack wirklich
so einfach haben
so haben wir doch basilikum finden wir
noch etwas anderes gut ich glaube da
haben wir eigentlich schon genug
verpackungsmüll das ärgert mich jetzt
schon nehmen trotzdem mit ich finde so
ein paar kräuter machen doch noch
einiges aus fertig eingekauft werden
hätte ich eingekauft habe ich habe jetzt
auch ziemlich hunger das ist unser
einkauf ich bin der christopher grant
ich bin heute zuständig zum einen um
euch zu unterstützen
kocht aktionen und zum anderen habe ich
die unangenehme aufgabe als neda zu
bewerten wenn ich mal gespannt packt ihr
ein graus
[Musik]
die spannung steigt
ihr seid flexibel und hat er anscheinend
für eine vegetarische bolognese soße
entschieden beziehungsweise auf jeden
fall sogar eine vegane ist auch die eier
was verbirgt sich denn dieser schachteln
wollen wir ja in den eiern mal
reinschauen
die habe ich nur als hülle genommen
grundsätzlich kann man sagen bei co2
bilanz gibt es einen deutlichen
unterschied zwischen pflanzlichen und
tierischen lebensmitteln die tierischen
erzeugung mehr co2 ich habe nen
unterschied zwischen bio und
konventionell bio steht wir sind besser
da bei der co2 bilanz regional spielten
rolle
regional ist besser als weit
transportiert saisonal spielt insofern
hätte ich jetzt tendenziell beide bio
ein kleines plus drauf gemacht wird auch
grün passt dann auch hoch und bei dem
konventionellen ein leichtes kleines -
das ist auch eine schwierige
diskussionen
das ist bio das ist gesund und
geschmackvolle kräuter dass es viel
plastik mit diesem topf auch noch ein
bisschen torch trend spiele aber nur
noch ganz kleine rolle am schluss umsatz
habe ich zwei blätter nur schluss
betrachtet das ding vielleicht in der wg
auf dem regal halten so hat mir auch
sehr weh beim kauf ich habe neun euro 48
11 eur 63
[Musik]
da sind ein paar extra zutaten die
hierbei teilweise fehlen die aber
erinnern die klassischen polonaise soße
rein gehören und ich darf euch verkünden
dass ihr aus diesen zutaten und zwei
joker quasi ihr könnt euch zwei zutaten
wählen besucher oder darüber dass wir
uns da jetzt noch aus und ich freu mich
drüber was ist nun eine testen uns mit
schwieriger bolognese soße zu testen
oder typische in eine typische
inhaltsstoffen ein vorlese
das ist knollensellerie knollensellerie
da würde ich mich für lob lauch und
knollensellerie entscheiden super sehr
gutes tut so gut weil ich wieder andere
sachen nehme ich wieder an karotten und
lauch nennt man eigentlich lauf werden
die knoblauch und wir haben einmal den
lauch und keine karotte wunderbar noch
haben sie sich nie ihr fragen habt ihr
euch zur verfügung
so musste den mittelfinger nach vorne
die anderen finger lässt hinten und
hiermit hälse phase die karotte fest und
hier vorn
die nächste seite sagt du bist mein
gerät nun kannst dich auf diese arbeiten
nicht schneiden meine sollen zehn
minuten köcheln und seien wahrscheinlich
auch durch ihr könnt mir gleich zu
kochen müssen aber ich hab es nie
gefühlt linsen sehen gut aus und ich
finde da sind müssen verkauft dann
mussten sie gas geben hier sage ich
jetzt deutlich dass geht der punkt auch
noch andere exklusive lass dir zeit
[Musik]
gleich dunkel draußen immer noch
ausständig
was hat erstmal erhitzen noch gehörig
die kreisel beim kochen ist dann machst
du das alles sehr guter tipp hier laufen
würde ich lieber herr knopp auch also
ich habe gehört dass sie sechs bis
sieben zehen ist nicht fehlt es nicht
also da würde ich anfangen mache ich
nicht hier sieht sehr düster aus für uns
kochen besteht zu 40 prozent aus putzen
also wie im leben dabei fing in kraft
gesetzt dass ich die mit sondern zitrone
mit einem schuss zitrone abbrechen will
es aber ganz gern wissen ja so der
yannick ist schon einmal ein listen only
das heißt gas gehen dafür durch
ansonsten geht der punkt schnelligkeit
an jannik wie weit bist du denn was
machen dann ist noch ein
so richtete sich nach 12 minuten nein
denn ich muss nochmal ganz doch noch mal
hinein willst doch das war mal mein
kollege lässt gerade sehr viel zeit noch
wie ich sehe zwar sehr aber es gefiel
ihm damals zum beispiel steht da
rangehen fertig
die männer das macht das was meinst du
kann deine rolle denn jetzt
geschmacklich und jetzt kannst du da
noch punkten heute und einiges rausholen
vielleicht hat der zitrone durch noch
ein getan hab ich mal gespannt
auch ein bisschen zornig linsen haben
wir haben noch haben doch bis 0 sind
schon al dente
das haben wir den pokal daten hier von
janneck erstmal schön aus garniert mit
aus silikon
sie ist nicht ganz klar ist aber man
kann satt werden sie schmeckt polonaise
hat ist jetzt nicht so viel zu tun
gehabt beide ungefähr das gleiche menü
gehabt insofern habt ihr beide rund 1,1
kilogramm co2 ausstoß für eure menü
insgesamt gehabt in der klassischen
variante mit rindfleisch wäre dass
deutlich mehr gewesen da werden bei
ungefähr 27 kilogramm gewesen was das
essen angeht gebe ich zwei punkte für
den geschmack und ich gebe mal einen
einzuleiten und auch einem dritten an
den lieben jannik dann geschmacklich war
diese polonaise tatsächlich weit vorn so
ich würde sagen da haben wir ganz klar
ein sieger
danke danke danke das ist sondern ganz
super gewesen
vielen dank an plan b dass wir heute
hier dabei sein durften wir haben noch
eine weitere challenge gemacht die
verlinken wir euch hier irgendwo klickt
einfach drauf und schreibt das auch
gerne mal in die kommentare
ob wir heute auch was gelernt habt oder
was ist noch so für alle varianten hier
gibt mir entspannung uns jetzt erstmal
oder sie